[Musica]
immaginiamo di avere una macchina del
tempo magari la mitica delorean del film
ritorno al futuro
programmiamo i circuiti del tempo le
facciamo un salto indietro di cinque
anni e il 23 giugno del 2013
siamo nel regno unito dove si vota per
il referendum consultivo sulla
permanenza o meno
nell'unione europea il famoso referendum
sulla break 11 tre maggiori partiti
britannici si schierano per restare
nell'unione 4 si schierano per uscire se
uno si schiera per come partito neutrale
la maggior parte della stampa britannica
internazionale in qualche modo ti fa per
regno unito resti l'unione europea ei
sondaggi sembrano confermare questo dato
poi si è votato e sappiamo tutti com'è
andata a finire
adesso andiamo avanti di qualche mese il
9 novembre nel 2016
siamo negli stati uniti dove si vota per
eleggere il quarantacinquesimo
presidente la sfida è tra hillary
clinton e donald trump
anche in questo caso la stampa americana
e internazionale è quasi tutta contro
trump i sondaggi anche durante la notte
elettorale a maggioranza danno avanti
hillary clinton ma anche in questo caso
sappiamo tutti com'è andata a finire
l'exit trump diventano ben presto due
simboli due indicatori di qualcosa che
fa cambiando profondamente e cioè il
nostro rapporto con la verità immediato
dall'innovazione tecnologica sono in
qualche modo due spie di un
disorientamento politico ma forse anche
oltre
sociale culturale non a caso nel 2016
l'oxford dictionary sceglierà posto
verità come parola dell'anno
sempre in quell'anno succede
qualcos'altro di interessante ai nostri
fini questa volta però a oriente
siamo a seoul in corea del sud tra il 9
e il 15 marzo appunto del 2016 si svolge
una partita go un antichissimo gioco da
tavola di strategia cinese tra l'iss e
dall in coreano 18 volte campione del
mondo e al fatto che è un software di
google di find go è un gioco semplice
come regole ma che prevede un numero di
combinazioni praticamente infinito per
questa ragione in cina come in corea
compreso il campione lisa dall tutti
erano convinti che la sfida sarebbe
finita 5 a 0 per l'umano contro la
macchina perché la tesi era una stupida
macchina non può battere un umano la
creatività umana in un gioco così poco
programmabile però al fatto così stupida
non è al faro si allena impara dagli
errori riesce addirittura essere
creativa
ad esempio nella seconda partita sia una
mossa la mossa numero 37 che lasciò il
mondo di stucco gli osservatori dissero
è una mossa che nessun umano avrebbe
fatto quella mossa fece vincere la
partita dal fatto che alla fine vinse la
sfida per 4 1
a differenza della sfida di 20 anni
prima a scacchi tra kasparov e deep blue
di ibm nel 1996
questa volta non abbiamo assistito solo
alla sconfitta di un umano contro la
macchina abbiamo assistito alla
sconfitta dell'intelligenza umana contro
l'intelligenza artificiale è un bel
salto concettuale per capirlo basti
pensare che l'anno dopo nel 2017 alfa 0
che era la versione successiva di alfaro
sfida a scacchi stop state che il
programma il software gli scacchi più
importanti del mondo e senza aver mai
giocato a scacchi imparando da sola in
quattro ore
vince oltre venti partite su 100 e non
ne perde neanche una
ora perché è importante questo evento
perché mentre in occidente l'abbiamo
abbastanza snobbato in oriente è stato
invece un evento molto importante in
cina è stato seguito da oltre 60 milioni
di spettatori
per queste ragioni si sostiene che è
questo fu lo sputnik momento il momento
diciamo che ha fatto cam comprendere al
governo cinese che era il momento di
investire pesantemente sull'intelligenza
artificiale e da quel momento decide di
puntare punto sfidare gli stati uniti la
silicon valley e puntare addirittura a
superarli entro il 2030 da inizio così a
la vera sfida del bipolarismo globale di
oggi che è la tecno mix war la guerra
economica sugli algoritmi l'intelligenza
artificiale
insomma il 2016 un anno ricco di
suggestioni per noi ne manca ancora uno
però è il 21 ottobre di quell'anno
quando su netflix la terza
di una serie tv britannica famosissimo
black mirror il primo episodio della
terza stagione si intitola caduta libera
nella versione italiana
quest'episodio narra la storia di lesi
una giovane donna in carriera in un
mondo in cui il punteggio che gli altri
ci attribuiscono determina la nostra
possibilità di avere privilegi diritti
libertà determina quindi lo status socio
economico e giuridico proprio dei
cittadini
lei si inizia l'episodio con un
punteggio abbastanza alto il massimo 5
stelle e lei era 4.3 per una serie di
vicissitudini e di imprevisti nell'arco
di 24 ore
crolla dal 4.3 a 0,6 e finisce
l'episodio in prigioni ora questa nel
2016 sembravano pura distopia oggi la
cina avanza a grandi passi verso il
social credit system o social credito
scorcio e punteggio che è esattamente la
cittadinanza a punti prefigurata da
black mirror ora parcheggiamo alla
delorean e torniamo ai giorni nostri a
come l'intelligenza artificiale può
essere appunto oggi una sfida per le
democrazie vestita alla democrazia
possono essere di due tipi interne o
esterne quelle interne hanno a che fare
con noi col popolo col demus appunto
cioè potremmo un certo punto non fidarsi
più di questo regime non ci piace più e
cerchiamo in qualche modo un'alternativa
non democratica quelle esterne invece
hanno a che fare con la sfida
geopolitica globale e quindi con
l'ipotesi che regimi non democratici
vincano quella sfida
partiamo con le sfide interne e partiamo
da una premessa importante tutti i
processi di automazione di
digitalizzazione già in corso sono un
vero e proprio paradiso per il
consumatore noi abbiamo un'offerta
customizza ta personalizzata che ci
viene incontro ci fa perdere poco tempo
e rispecchia i nostri gusti e le nostre
preferenze ma anche tutti i sistemi le
reti ai lavori che si stanno
automatizzando tra un po la chirurgia
prevederà una serie di robo chirurghi
che hanno le maniche non tremano non
hanno diritti sindacali
vanno in ferie non hanno problemi
stipendiali e saranno verosimilmente
tutti integrati in una rete globale per
cui saranno anche tutti aggiornabili in
tempo reale tutto questo chiaramente va
benissimo e non c'è nulla da obiettare
se lo guardiamo da utenti consumatori
diverso è il caso se lo guardiamo da
cittadini elettori perché perché tutti
questi sistemi si basano su quello che è
stato definito il capitalismo della
sorveglianza poche grandi ricchissime
aziende che detengono su di noi una
quantità di dati unica e su quei dati
lucrano generano profitto generano
crescita il problema di questa crescita
perché una crescita che non generare
distribuzione però c'è la produttività
aumenta i salari medi no
il risultato è che oggi gli uomini
cinque uomini più ricchi del mondo hanno
un patrimonio cumulato pari al pil della
svizzera sarebbero in cinque il
ventesimo paese più ricco del mondo
aggiungiamo al problema della
disuguaglianza quindi della
distribuzione delle risorse
il problema della disoccupazione perché
c'è sempre un trade off tra capitale e
lavoro c'è uno scambio appunto tra
capitale e lavoro in questi processi di
automazione per generare crescita si
sostituisce il costo del lavoro con
l'automazione ora si stima che da qui al
2030 quasi il 50 per cento dei lavori
attualmente presenti nel mondo sparirà
e a chi dice vabbè come al solito
saranno sostituiti da altri lavori come
è sempre successo dipende non è detto
che questa volta sia proprio così perché
pensiamo a un lavoratore a bassa
qualifica è facilmente e rapidamente
riconvertibile in un programmatore
intelligenza artificiale o qualcosa del
genere
non credo quindi redistribuzione delle
risorse e occupazione disoccupazione
sono due problemi seri per la democrazia
sono due problemi seri per che
polarizzano dividono perché generano una
domanda pubblica importante generano
aspettative è spesso generano anche odio
rabbia risentimento talvolta addirittura
dolore
al di là di questi due primi temi c'è
poi il tema classico quello appunto già
affrontato in parte
ricordando la breve
assiste trump che il tema delle
informazioni e della manipolazione
online
noi dobbiamo tenere presente una cosa
l'essere umano non essere motivo siamo
esseri guidati dalle emozioni in
politica le emozioni si accendono di più
in politiche più facile che si incendi
diciamo il nostro tribalismo del nostro
essere riparte il nostro essere tifosi e
questo ovviamente divide la società non
la unisce se pensiamo che gli algoritmi
delle piattaforme online sono costruiti
proprio come modello di business per
infiammarsi più perché quelle cose
general ping agent è chiaro che
l'intelligenza artificiale anche da quel
punto di vista non sta remando a favore
della tenuta democratica
il problema è che quando non si
condivide più nulla con gli avversari
politici spesso diventano nemici da
censurare o addirittura da eliminare e
quando ciò accade la democrazia a
rischio anzi probabilmente già finita
ora passiamo alle sfide esterne perché
accanto al capitalismo della
sorveglianza c'è lo stato della
sorveglianza a shenzhen in cina
se qualcuno attraverso le strisce
pedonali col rosso vedrà immediatamente
il suo volto e il suo nome proiettati su
un monitor enorme mirato ovviamente a
suscitare vergogna e riprovazione
sociale ma anche a dirti che lo stato ti
osserva big brother and is watching you
di orwelliana memoria
in cina ci sono 600 milioni di
telecamere integrate e con software di
riconoscimento facciale per di più quasi
un miliardo di cittadini paga quasi
tutto tramite smart sempre col
riconoscimento facciale questo genera
una mole di dati impressionante per il
diciamo machine learning del regime
cinese sembra sia quello poi costruisce
appunto il sistema il social che di
sistemi di cui abbiamo parlato prima
cioè la cittadinanza a punti e cioè la
possibilità di accedere o meno a diritti
e libertà
la cina tuttavia guarda anche fuori dai
propri confini con il bel the road
project così almeno lo definiscono negli
stati uniti cerca di esportare in
qualche modo infrastrutture tecnologie e
sistemi parecchio ad oggi siano già 58 i
paesi coinvolti
non a caso è stato di recente coniato
formula della cortina di bambù come la
nuova cortina di ferro o della cold war
la guerra del codice al posto della
vecchia cold war la guerra fredda
novecentesca tra stati uniti e unione
sovietica
ovviamente la co2 una guerra economica
per ora prevalentemente che si basa
appunto sull'intelligenza artificiale
come si salva allora la democrazia
allora intanto riportando al centro del
campo di gioco un grande assente finora
che è stato la politica la politica in
cina è molto presente come abbiamo visto
nella politica democratica
fino ad oggi ha preferito o subire o
cavalcare queste innovazioni
tecnologiche mentre ha faticato molto
nel provare a guidarle o gestirli con
una sorta di visione
chiaramente per riportare al centro la
politica è necessario la politica esca
da quel vicolo cieco in cui si è
cacciata recentemente negli anni della
cosiddetta campagna elettorale
permanente un vicolo cieco fatto di uno
schiacciamento sul presente di
gratificazioni immediate effetti
annuncio di leader che in realtà
inseguono l'opinione pubblica che
sembrano quindi più dei follower
dell'opinione pubblica piuttosto che
appunto dei leader di una democrazia che
sta diventando sempre più una specie di
fondo grazia permanente appunto una
politica che insegue gli sciami del
pubblico per riposizionarsi di volta in
volta tutto questo non ha visione tutto
questo non costruisce nulla nel medio
lungo periodo soprattutto non dà un
senso presente la crisi democratica
contemporanea è prima di tutto una crisi
di senso cioè mancano storie condivise
che ci permettano di orientarci nel
presente
chiaramente essendo disorientati nel
presente abbiamo anche una scarsa
fiducia nel futuro dunque l'altra parola
chiave da richiamare in questo caso e
visione ci abbiamo bisogno di una classe
dirigente di un modello di leadership
che sia in grado di orientarsi nel
presente di riempire quel vuoto di
futuro l'ultima parola chiave un'altra
parola di moda di questi tempi e
resilienza
ora la cina probabilmente oggi può
sembrare più resiliente di diverse
democrazie occidentali cioè più capace
di resistere alle sfide dei nemici
esterni o dei nemici interni
tuttavia lo scenario competitivo di oggi
è talmente volatile disordinato e
prevedibile che forse non è tanto quello
della resilienza il valore chiave quanto
quello dell'elasticità dell'anti
fragilità cioè della capacità di
imparare dagli errori di trasformare i
pericoli e le crisi in opportunità di
rinascere più forti di prima
e questo può farlo meglio un sistema
aperto che un sistema chiuso la cina
allora può essere come deep blue dbm
vincere la partita a scacchi del
presente al futuro sembra sempre di più
una partita di go più che mettono più
che una partita a scacchi cioè appunto
pieno di variabili è privo di costanti e
allora forse più che di più serve al
faro e nessuno somiglia a dal fado più
di una democrazia liberale
ricordiamoci però che la sua anti
fragilità dipende da noi siamo noi i
programmatori del nostro futuro in
qualche modo la deep mind della
democrazia e a proposito di mind
possiamo salvarla solo se impariamo a
conoscere l'uomo prima della macchina